it's a battle of Big Ideas in the fight
for 2020 president Trump ramping up the
rhetoric and going after his Democratic
rivals including Joe Biden after a
report saying allies want the former VP
to scale back his schedule because of
his gaffes
you got Pocahontas is rising got
Kabbalah Kumalo is falling
you got Vado bado is like God I think
sleepy Joe may be able to limp across
the finish line but today they announced
that they're going to cut way back on
his appearances because he is such a
disaster you have no choice but to vote
for me because your 401ks down the tubes
everything's going to be down the tubes
so whether you love me or hate me you
gotta vote for me
while Trump unleashes those attacks
Democrats are taking a much different
approach to try to win the White House
The Washington Post pointing out the
candidates are promising to offset
voters quote anxieties and concerns with
a return to normalcy via a president who
is everything they believe Trump is not
measured predictable responsible or at
its most reductive they're offering an
unofficial pledge to make America boring
again here's some of the 2020 hopefuls
vowing to act the opposite of Trump I'm
not going around doing crazy things just
looking for a viral moment I said the
other day that you know if you let me
president you can count on there being
two weeks to go by when you don't need
to think of
my name is Joe Biden I'm running for in
this case running for president on stage
look me over you like what you see how
the other person of what we've been
seeing it's it is tiring
okay so Dana I want to ask you about the
two strategies one Kay the advisors
belief that maybe Jo's great in the
morning but in the afternoon gets a
little tired sort of thinking about
scaling back his schedule and to what do
you think about the Democrats trying to
be boring okay I think that the strategy
of having Biden dude less if you're
worried about poll numbers is probably
good because he had maintained his poll
numbers at the highest levels until he
started doing more appearances right and
then as he started doing more
appearances he started to slip and also
because others are ramping things up
like Elizabeth Warren her organization
is really good so if they think that it
will help him be able to maintain until
he gets to a general lineup now I don't
think that speaks well to the idea of
how he would do
mano-a-mano against President Trump so
then the question of electability I
think gets asked again but his poll
numbers have stayed pretty high even
though he has made some gas but they
have started to slip being boring again
I guess in some ways you I think that
most people are like look there's going
to be a chunk of people about 35% of the
country that are gonna be out there
chanting four more years and they can't
get enough and they would they just love
it they can't wait for the president to
be reelected then they're gonna have
like 35 percent saying we've got to have
a return to normalcy we can't take this
anymore
and then I think that the swing voters
are gonna be if you look down at this
choice as he said love me or hate me
right yeah you have to choose me because
they'll say well it's only four more
years did you want to say something
about these strategies well on the first
point I think the opposite of what the
Republicans call trump derangement
syndrome which they attach to anybody
who's concerned about trump is trump
anxiety syndrome and I think the
psychiatrist a psychologist of all said
yes
people are more anxious with Trump
another I mean just this week
Trump goes out he went after the Federal
Reserve he went after I think he advised
Israel to borrow those two congresswoman
from entering their country nobody ever
saw a president ever do that before you
know even Republicans Marco Rubio Kevin
McCarthy said oh no no that's not a good
idea a lot of people even the Jewish
community not a good idea don't do that
I mean it never stops with this guy and
so of course people are going to say
we'd like to get back to normal I just
don't know if that's an inspiring
message great I think what's going on is
yes to Biden 2020 America needs a nap
okay so let's talk about this public
America needs a break from no but I want
to dress this and I'll show you the
hypocrisy in this idea the boring
approach is based on a fact that Donald
Trump can be exhausting he's packed 12
years into three years and we know that
the right and the left understand that
but now the Democrats know how we feel
they hate waking up every morning having
to face the news of Trump that every
morning they have to deal with Trump
well that's been what it's been like for
a conservative or a Republican for the
past 4050 years
modern left is left ISM has injected
politics into every part of our lives
sports entertainment sex gender our kids
we're suffocating under leftism it's
everywhere everything we wake up and we
have we're faced with it in our culture
so now we finally got somebody who's
throwing it back in your face every day
he said oh you want to pick on us well
screw you and it goes back to that
polarization myth that the media keeps
talking about oh these are polarizing
times it's only polarizing times because
finally the second poll showed up right
for the longest time there was only one
tent pole it was the left owned the ball
they owned the stadium they owned the
field they entertained the Accademia
social media now you got a guy who's
saying I'm here and I'm gonna on the
other poll now the gauche it's
polarizing almost swore but I'm telling
you this is all garbage is this all
garbage they are mad because they have
to fight about time it's a great point
Ben she and Biden is just that it to me
kind of screams of him being in trouble
and he needs a timeout so to me it's a
public admission of a failure and he
reminds me of the family of although we
growing up a stationwagon 300,000 miles
on it it's not inspiring anybody it's
just getting you from A to B but it
plays into that larger conversation of
our Democrats gonna vote where their
heads or their hearts and with their
heads in the past where they were
playing it safe and falling in line it
was a disaster with Carrie and Goran
Dukakis or maybe this time around
obviously it's kind of a toss-up what's
gonna happen in the in the general and I
think it's funny that people like Dick
Harpootlian in South Carolina are
hosting fundraisers and saying well
there's something to be said for two
white guys going at it
it's not about Medicare it's not about
the green new anything it's about
getting this juvenile narcissist out
they are freaking out and in my response
to what you were saying about them
saying well Trump is exhausting he's
always in the news I feel like it's when
people say that I go too fast in life
and I'm like sorry not sorry you can't
keep up I think you had the rally last
night in the end what you just said but
the fact is even as he says vote for me
if you hate me or love me and the
economy will sink it but you don't vote
for me
you know what Fox poll this week showed
like 2/3 of Americans say he's tearing
us apart as a country that's very real
that was actionable that was an actual
poll they said that yeah they said
tearing people up with country Harry
he's tearing the picture I think the
media is tearing the co included